hi welcome to part 2 of game theory and
Breaking Bad where we'll discuss the
importance of thinking ahead in the
first part we describe the difference
between decision theory which was static
and game theory which is dynamic in this
scene we're going to make the claim that
early on in the show
Jesse's actions are very much in line
with a decision theory framework whereas
Walt's actions are much more in line
with the game theoretic framework we're
going to show that in a scene from 737
the background is that Walt and Jesse
have just seen Tuco beat up and kill a
guy in a drug deal for absolutely no
reason
Tuco is absolutely crazy they don't know
who they're dealing with they're over
their heads and they fear that Tuco is
going to come after them either because
he wants to take revenge for no reason
or because their witness to him
murdering someone for their own safety
they decide they need to take action and
in the following scene Jesse describes
his plan to shoot Tuco
you
all right so now let's get to an
analysis of the scene we want to
demonstrate why Jessie represents
decision theory and Walt represents game
theory this is very easily seen just by
the idea that the each of them have
Jesse's ideas very simple just we need
to take action I'm going to get a gun
and shoot Tuco Walt things things
through a lot more it's not just that we
can shoot Tuco the question is if we
shoot Tuco what will be the reaction
will there be people around will we be
able to escape will the plan actually
work and this gets to the difference
between a decision theory framework and
that the planning is just to collect the
data and come up with your best course
of action but in game theory you need to
collect a lot more information you not
only need to think about your possible
actions do you have one
bullet to bullet so forth when are you
going to do this you also need to think
about the strategies that are available
to your opponents in this case Walt
realizes that Tuco's men are going to be
prepared for this they have to be on
guard too they will have a defense so
what are they going to do about this the
result of this little discussion is that
Jesse learns is just very difficult that
he's way over his head
and this will be an important threat
throughout the series that Jesse learns
more he learns to not just think things
through like an impulsive druggie he
actually learns how to have strategic
thinking Walt just realizes that they
need a very sophisticated plan that it
was very nice to Jesse to try but it's
not going to be that simple
and in part three we're going to show an
example of just how far Walt is willing
to go to show that they're powerful and
that they can take down to go so I hope
you join us for part three and thank you
for watching you can also follow me on
mind your decisions or at pressure
Walker